[Musique]
le 7-8 journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le
mercredi 13 mars tout de suite les
titres de cette édition
il est prévu pour 2021 troisième
cimetière doit être édifiée à voisins le
bretonneux les élus ont validé sa
construction en novembre dernier en lieu
et place du square des 40 arpents le
projet de 460 sépulture et contestés par
un collectif d'habitants explications à
suivre en ce mois de mars les jeunes se
mobilisent face à l'urgence
environnementale alternatiba versailles
et citoyen pour le climat profite de la
démarche avec leur printemps pour le
futur une marque qui se tiendra à ce
samedi dans la cité royale nous en
parlons avec et deux des organisateurs
vincent hospital et charlène dansant et
ce week-end c'est le douzième et
cauterets un parcours notamment de 80
kilomètres entre saint quentin en
yvelines et la tour eiffel parmi les
douze mille participants 1 par ea
triathlète versailles à brice marmonnier
courra pour sensibiliser sur
l'importance d'appareiller les jeunes
amputés avec une lame il est notre
invité avant de développer ses titres 30
postes supprimés à l'hippodrome de
maisons laffitte la direction de france
galop et les syndicats ont signé un plan
de sauvegarde de l'emploi qui prévoit
ces suppressions sur les 42 salariés du
site
une décision suite à l'annoncé en
novembre dernier de l'arrêt des courses
sur place et de la réorganisation du
centre d'entraînement ce pse appliqué à
l'automne concernerait les employés les
plus âgés qui devrait toucher 70 % de
leur salaire pendant deux ans et demi
elle est douce postes restants vont
faire l'objet de négociations engagées
dans les prochains mois trois hommes
originaire de trappes condamné par le
tribunal de grande instance de paris des
peines allant de quatre à six ans
d'emprisonnement emprisonnement pour
avoir envoyé des fonds à des djihadistes
français en syrie
plusieurs milliers d'euros mais aussi
des vêtements adressées notamment à
walid hammam cadres de l'état islamique
tué fin 2016 les trois hommes avaient
été arrêtés par la dgs i en janvier 2017
à voisins le bretonneux ils protestent
contre la construction d'un troisième
cimetière sur le square des à quarante
arpents un collectif s'est créé pour
rassembler les oppositions ce projet a
été voté lors d'un conseil municipal en
novembre 2018 les détails sur la
situation avec ce dossier de marne ont
varaldo et nicolas dont prix ils ne
veulent pas qu'on touche à leur square
le collectif des 40 arpents s'opposent
au projet de construction d'un troisième
cimetière vie si noah sur cet espace
vert
un groupe créé en février dernier en
lien avec l'association de défense des
habitants de voisins-le-bretonneux
terrain ne répond pas à la demande et à
la tente à moyen long terme c'est ça le
vrai sujet ce cimetière des 40 arpents
pourrait accueillir 467 culture sur un
terrain de 4800 mètres carrés on
respecte sur le plan les 35 m 2 des
habitations que ce soit ici ou ici
évidemment et puis l'idée c'est d'avoir
un parc un cimetière parc alors avec une
clôture un mur c'est parce que ça c'est
une obligation qui sont que ce soit joli
mur qu'on puisse mais aussi des arbres
moi je souhaite travailler avec eux sur
le visuel qu'ils peuvent avoir
d'après la municipalité ce nouveau
cimetière est obligatoire pour combler
le manque d espace dans les sites
existants
les 120 places au pied de l'église de
voisins-le-bretonneux et le cimetière
des tilleuls et ses 380 sépulture le
square des 40 arpents était dans la
balance avec le site du champ du loup
avec des études déjà réalisées sur ce
lieu il ya lancé mais il ya des anciens
élus de voisins qui m'ont toujours dit
que le cimetière il allait être à
saturation
donc depuis 2001 on en parle et que ce
ce cimetière devait se faire au champ du
loup le terrain qu'ils avaient été visés
à l'époque qui était tout au bout du
terrain de rugby en lisière de la forêt
était vraiment très complexe à utiliser
d'abord il fallait supprimer des
terrains de foot ensuite le terrain
n'était pas du tout viabilisés et en
plus proche d'une nappe phréatique ce
qui n'est pas très bon ménage avec un
cimetière voit l'entrée du champ du loup
sur le côté voilà il ya une grande
étendue aussi la mélasse appartient à
saint quentin en yvelines
de son côté l'opposition a formulé une
demande au préfet pour faire annuler la
délibération portant la création de ce
nouveau cimetière là des citoyens
également engagé à guyancourt où un
collectif vient de se créer
décidons ensemble à guyancourt réuni des
habitants pour un objectif de présenter
une liste pour les élections municipales
en 2020 une priorité celle de la
démocratie participative hier une
réunion était organisée sur le thème
bien vivre dans mon quartier des rendez
vous qui se tiennent sous forme
d'ateliers pour réfléchir et formuler
des propositions en vue d'un programme
le collectif se laisse jusqu'à septembre
pour le construire avant de constituer
une liste candidate pour le scrutin les
propos sont recueillis par manon varaldo
d'une initiative qui est parti de
citoyens citoyennes de la ville souvent
investis en milieu associatif
on a plutôt dans l'est on va dire seul
en militant dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire
la transition écologique en garde il ya
beaucoup de questions qui tournent sans
démocratie participative comment est-ce
qu'on mettra en oeuvre la démarche avec
reims participative parce que j'ai eu
recours à une échelle particulière donc
on n'applique pas la même manière
suivant les échelles de guide
ensuite les question c'est comment qu'on
créera le programme comme montrer
réaliste comment pouvoir faire en sorte
que tous les citoyens puissent apporter
leur pierre à l'édifice
comment pouvoir me faire en sorte que
chaque chaque idée puis c'est valoriser
sur leur programme mais la maire
sortante divers-gauche marie-christine
le tarnec n'a elle pas encore indiqué si
elle était ou non candidate pour ce
scrutin en 2020 les jeunes mobilisés sur
la question du climat à vendredi c'est
la grève mondiale pour le climat
organisée par used for climate ce week
end des actions citoyennes se tiennent
également dans plus de 130 villes de
france c'est le cas à versailles pour en
parler deux invités charlène vincent et
vincent hospital bonsoir à vous deux
pour ça alors janine vincent vous êtes
membres d'alternative à versailles
vincent hospital citoyens pour le climat
versailles et vous qu organisé ce samedi
le printemps pour le futur c'est une
marche au départ est de la place d'armes
à versailles entre 11h et 13h et ce sera
d'ailleurs la troisième marche organisée
sur l'urgence climatique de dans la
ville est ce que c'est un rendez-vous
qui mobilise à chaque fois ce genre de
marche à versailles est ce que c'est une
vraie mobilisation sur le sujet oui nous
avions 400 personnes à la première
marche du 8 décembre et quasiment 700 à
celle du 27 janvier
donc c'est toujours un rendez vous qui
mobilise là l'objectif de ce nouveau
rendez vous qui se tient ce samedi quels
sont ses objectifs
je ne sais pas si on est vraiment fixer
enfin d'être spectaculaire en fait à
organiser un frozen sur la place d'armes
devant le château d'accord un sit-in sur
la place du marché et un capping devant
le lycée hoche un frozen qu'est ce que
c'est un art frozen c'est qu'on va
demander à tout le monde d'adopter une
position
qui lui va bien qui correspond à ce
qu'il a envie d'exprimer sur le moment
et de rester figé pendant 3 minutes et
clapping on voit un peu plus ce que
c'est si on va regarder le foot
récemment et les déclas ping sont sont
de mise en ce moment alors le mois de
mars the lady est marquée par la
mobilisation pour le climat une
mobilisation des jeunes est ce que c'est
important en tout cas un pas
considérable que les jeunes se
saisissent aujourd'hui de cette
thématique cette thématique de l'urgence
climatique
enfin pour moi c'est primordial parce
que c'est surtout pour eux
en fait il ya des personnes aujourd'hui
qui se battent enfin mais c'est surtout
pour les jeunes donc c'est hyper
important je pense que ce soit
aujourd'hui qu'ils disent bas aux états
au gouvernement voilà qui feint qui
montrent qu'ils veulent prendre en main
leur avenir à eux
et voilà c'est enfin je trouve ça
vraiment super qu'ils se mettent à faire
grève justement donc ça te rapporte
d'ailleurs au nom de la manifestation
printemps pour le futur c'est à dire ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui va servir pour
les générations à venir
oui ça concerne c'est bien que les
jeunes s'en saisisse parce qu'ils sont
concernés et ça prouve aussi que la
prise de conscience s'est élargi à
toutes les générations et ça c'est
important
et le futur c'est le futur de tout le
monde et c'est pas le futur de ces pas
2100 on parle des échéances à 2030 2040
2050 conseil avoir des surprises alors
dans votre communiqué de presse commun
annonçant et ce printemps pour le futur
vous l'affirmer il reste moins de deux
ans pour agir
c'est ça oui bah c'est surtout le
rapport du giec 1 qui l'affirmé enfin
sceller des experts 1 c'est pas nous
donc voilà
l'idée c'est de vraiment enfin la coop
21 les engagements sont a priori pas
suffisant il faut aller plus loin
donc aujourd'hui on se mobilise je pense
que au sein de nos deux collectifs on
agit nous mêmes au quotidien mais là on
a envie de dire au gouvernement aux
mairies aux états que c'est aussi à eux
de prendre les choses en main parce que
tout seul on va pas d'arriver en fait
dont vous parlez qui s'est tenue en 2015
à paris le giec d'ailleurs qui parle
d'un réchauffement de limiter le
réchauffement à 1,5 degré on parle plus
souvent de 2 degrés le giec lui
moby sur 1,5 degré oui c'est très
important car déjà il ya une notion
aussi très important de savoir c'est que
la même s'ils ont respecté les accords
de paris on arriverait en 2100 un
réchauffement de 3 ou 4 degrés d'accord
ça c'est énorme
ensuite entre un ennemi et 2 degrés il
ya une différence énorme les
conséquences sont absolument pas les
mêmes notamment en terme de biodiversité
ou d'accès à l'eau et donc de rendements
agricoles et le nombre de millions de
gens impacté n'est pas du tout de même
si on reste à un degré demi ou à 2
degrés du coup ce genre de match que
vous organisez dont la prochaine est à
versailles samedi c'est plutôt pour
sensibiliser la population faire
pression sur le gouvernement sur les
pouvoirs publics qu'elle est 2e
il faut à la fois que l'ensemble de la
population prenne conscience des enjeux
liés au dérèglement climatique est
également que le les décideurs d'une
manière générale politique ou pas qu'on
traîne qu'il y a adoption de la
compréhension de la nécessité et ça les
pousse à agir ils se disent ce n'est pas
des barrières et puis que eux mêmes
comprennent qu'il faut maintenant agir
il ya en ce moment le grand débat
national qui va s'achever en fin de
semaine est l'un des quatre grands
thèmes en tout cas promis par le
président de la république c'est la
transition écologique vous y voyez
plutôt en effet d'annonce où il ya une
vraie volonté d'aller de l'avant
comment vous le voyez enfin après c'est
plutôt d
d ça bien de moi c'est personnel pour
moi c'est plus en effet d'annonce parce
qu'on sait que la démission nicolas
hulot a fait mal enfin c'est un peu ça
qu'à réveiller cac a lancé un peu les
marchés en france en tout cas c'est
ministre de la transition écologique
directement donc voila moi c'est mon
avis à moi mais bon en espérant que ça
donne quelque chose quand même mais il
que faut-il concrètement aujourd'hui
vous disiez des mesures des mesures des
pouvoirs publics quel genre de mesures
par exemple bas typiquement nous on
pousse à l'adoption du pacte finances
qui m'a c'est à dire créer une banque
européenne pour le climat qui serait
capable de démettre des landes quantité
de monnaie dirigés vers les
investissements pour la transition
écologique notamment l'isolation des
bâtiments avec un suivi faut que ce soit
des services publics qui suivent les
experts qui vont mettre ça en place
c'est que c'est la bonne mise en place
soit soit suivi et on parle de d'une
enveloppe qui correspondrait à 2% du pib
de chaque pays d'europe
donc c'est plusieurs milliers de
milliards d'euros mais ça a été a été
émis pour sauver les banques au moment
de la crise financière en 2008 on peut
tout à fait le faire pour sauver le
climat
c'est même une raison bien plus valable
nous nous reste une ultime revient du
coup à cette marche de samedi on l'a
compris vous en avez parler un peu du
programme
au début il ya un côté festif aussi qui
sera une volonté de votre part samedi
oui il faut rester positif
il ya de l'espoir on a les solutions
donc il faut juste les porter et il faut
pour cela rester constructif
donc rendez vous fixé à 11h sur la place
d'armes au château de versailles devant
le château de versailles
venez le plus nombreux possible et donc
c'est cette marche se déroulera ce
samedi merci à vous de charline vincent
pour rester un intime à versailles et
vincent hospital pour collectif le
collectif citoyen pour le climat et je
rappelle que vous organisez donc cette
marche qui a lieu ce samedi à versailles
c'est la 14e semaine la 14e édition de
la semaine nationale du rein des
dépistages anonymes et gratuits sont
proposés sur tout le territoire français
pendant cette semaine afin de détecter
notamment les insuffisances rénales qui
sont en progression en france reportage
au sein de la clinique et de saint
germain en laye avec manon varaldo
l'insuffisance rénale l'une des
priorités de la nouvelle stratégie de
santé qui souhaite notamment développer
la prévention de cette maladie chronique
transrail propose des dépistages
gratuits et à
anonyme comme ici à la clinique de saint
germain en laye ça permet de dépister
assez tôt les maladies et de prendre en
charge et de faire un suivi régulier
les patients doivent le faire une fois
par an c'était l'occasion et je crois
que c'est une bonne opportunité parce
qu'effectivement amont un jeune je
pensais pas forcément ce dépistage dure
dix minutes examen rapide des questions
sont au programme
c'est important de prendre et vérifier
la tension pour justement détecter les
maladies cardiaques et également rénale
on leur demande s'ils aussi ils ont des
antécédents familiaux parce que ça joue
beaucoup et puis on fait un recueil de
données donc on l'est pèse on prend leur
glycémie leur tour de taille et puis on
leur demande d'uriner dans un pot
bouffard une bandelette urinaire
le service de dialyse de la clinique de
saint germain en laye accueille environ
40 personnes par jour pour une dialyse
de trois à cinq heures suivant la
corpulence de la personne un dépistage
précoce permet une prise en charge
appropriée
le test urinaire permet de détecter
toute trace de sang ou encore de
leucocytes suivant la couleur
ben contre on trempe la bandelette dans
le green
suivant cette bandelette la machine nous
détecte tous les tous les problèmes qui
peut y avoir ou pas de problème la
maladie rénale est dite silencieuse elle
ne se manifeste par aucun symptôme
perceptible en france plus d'un tiers
des personnes entrent en urgence en
traitement de suppléance greffe ou
dialyse le rhin qui ne fonctionne plus
donc on compense cette cette pathologie
en filtrant en fait le sang de la
personne en éliminant l'eau et les
électrolytes une toxiques pour
l'organisme
cette quatorzième semaine nationale du
rein vis plus largement à sensibiliser
le grand public aux problématiques
relatives aux maladies rénales
je pense qu'ils importent important de
sensibiliser les gens toutes les
maladies parce qu on entend le jamais
les nombres de malades concernés par
l'insuffisance rénale augmentent de 2 %
par an le sport l'eco-trail partira
cette année encore de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'événement
qui attend douze mille participants se
déroule ce week-end plusieurs parcours
18 30 45 ou 80 kilomètres entre l'île de
loisirs et la tour eiffel et qui se
terminera notamment par une ascension de
la dame de fer c'est un défi physique
auquel prendra part brice marmonnier
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes parra
triathlète interne
sionnel originaire de versailles et vous
allez courir samedi le 80 km avec votre
lame une première avec un but solidaire
est celui de sensibiliser le public sur
l'importance d'appareiller les jeunes
amputés avec une lame on va en parler
dans un instant sinaï une action pour
l'association entraide une lame pour
courir avec le concours de plusieurs
partenaires dont l'association nouvelles
du vivre ensemble pourquoi c'est une
démarche qui vous tient à coeur cette
participation moi je suis je suis un
athlète handisport depuis quatre ans
suite à un grave accident de la route
j'ai fait le choix d'être amputé et je
suis actuellement à peut-être de haut
niveau avec la chance d'avoir un sponsor
au c'ur qui me fournit mon matériel est
aujourd'hui en fait en pratiquant le
sport de haut niveau je me suis rendu
compte que beaucoup d'enfants en fait
n'était pas du tout équipés parce que le
système français leur paye les prothèses
de vie mais absolument à aucun moment
les prothèses de sport donc en fait il
ya une association les deux lames pour
courir via entraide et son fondateur
jean luc heymans ont qui ont qui ont mis
ce programme en place et payer des lames
en carbone aux enfants pour qu'ils
puissent accéder au sport comme
n'importe quel enfant et évoluer à
l'intérieur de ça donc ça nous permet
aujourd'hui de leur offrir des larmes de
les suivre ce que le coût est vraiment
important venez suivre tout au long de
leur croissance et de leur fournir une
dernière prothèse définitive qu'on
appelle à l'âge de 19 ans pour qu'ils
puissent s'élancer dans leur vie leur
vie des sportifs qui vont d'ailleurs
courir certains enfants de ces enfants
équipés de lames le premier kilomètre
départ de l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines et vous le disiez
être équipé d'une lame ça change leur
vie ça permet d'avoir une vie lavis
d'encre pervers pour un enfant pas
d'être normale entre guillemets puisque
la société elle nous place dans une case
qu'est le handicap mais néanmoins quand
on les voit évoluer je vous invite à
venir les voir au départ c'est juste
impressionnant de les voir évoluer avec
leurs lames pour eux c'est la normalité
aujourd'hui et à certains vont peut-être
faire un kilomètre avec moi d'autres
peut-être beaucoup moins parce qu'on est
quand même sur dutreil les ce n'est pas
forcément évident voilà moi ma
participation c'est de montrer que bah
on peut avoir un handicap mais on peut
aussi parcourir des grosses distance on
peut relever des gros défis et quelque
part voilà moi mon but c'est exactement
celui là c'est de se dire on repousse
constamment les limites du handicap vous
parliez de votre histoire personnelle
cet accident à moto en 2004 et vous avez
fait le choix par la suite d'être amputé
vous étiez déjà sportif à l'époque
rugbyman je crois c'est ça moi je fais
mes études en préparation physique de
rugbyman j'ai touché à beaucoup de
sports différents
j'ai toujours évolué dans le milieu du
sport j'ai un diplôme ans
en préparation physique du rugbyman en
médecine sportive j'ai un diplôme
d'éducateur sportif donc j'ai vraiment
évolué là dedans et mon choix d'être
amputé en 2015 c'était pour retourner
dans le sport de haut niveau
donc aujourd'hui c'est mission accomplie
en depuis vous avez été champion de
france d'aviron vice-champion de france
de triathlon et vous avez terminé
troisième lors de la dernière coupe du
monde aux états unis être équipé d'une
lame ça a été un vrai renouveau pour
vous or moi est équipé d'une lame s'est
tout simplement il est équipé de
prothèses
voilà j'ai eu un grave accident j'ai eu
28 opérations on à faire amputer une
jambe broyée à le fait de choisir d'être
amputé c'est un vrai choix dans la vie a
néanmoins aujourd'hui avec le matériel
qui abat vous m'avez vu tout à l'heure
ça se voit pas forcément quand je marche
quand je cours le fed est équipé bas ça
me permet de retrouver des aptitudes qui
sont proches du moment j'étais valley de
voir même peut-être mieux puisque
aujourd'hui je suis plus entraîné avec
mon statut d'athlète de haut niveau et
mon entraînement biquotidien donc
donc voilà aujourd'hui danser c'est que
du bonheur si vous me passez
l'expression est de fixer aussi des
nouveaux objectifs l'année prochaine
il ya un objectif pour vous c'est de
participer aux jeux de tokyo
ben ali des dents tout sportif de haut
niveau et à partir du moment où on
arrive à un certain niveau c'est d'aller
chercher assez d'aller chercher toujours
plus haut un premier défi c'est 80 km
surprend un amputé en trail c'est un
très très grosse distance
et puis oui bien sûr j'ai dans la tête
qu'il ya les jeux olympiques qui arrive
dans 18 mois et et pourquoi pas se
donner les moyens d'y arriver
vous disiez tout à l'heure les l'homme
aujourd'hui c'est un équipement qui
coûte cher c'est ça ouais c'est à une
lame bon rapport à un adulte j'ai le
tarif en tête c'est entre 10 et 15 milo
avec avec l'envoi turc il faut
renouveler deux fois par an sur la
partie en voiture et la lame en elle
même qui doit coûter 5 6000 euros a
convenu elle tous les deux ans donc il
ya un véritable coup et imaginer sur un
enfant avec la croissance la prise de
masse musculaire là bas le fait que les
segments osseux s'agrandissent il faut
constamment faire évoluer le matériel ça
sert un véritable coup et aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas mon bon c'est par la sécurité
sociale
ils prennent en charge ce qui est déjà
pas mal hein les prothèses de vie mais
met pas cette partie sportive
il faudrait du coup aujourd'hui le
l'objectif c'est pour vous de
sensibiliser ces deux peut-être faire
avancer les mentalités soit peut-être
faire évoluer les mentalités peut-être
permettra aux enfants de pouvoir accéder
au sport comme n'importe quel enfant
valide entre guillemets c'est aussi leur
donner la chance d'état d'être accompli
et de pouvoir s'épanouir comme n'importe
quel enfant après aujourd'hui on a des
belles associations une lame pour courir
et puis on a d'autres qui nous
permettent justement de financer de
financer et d'accompagner ses enfants
mais c'est vrai que voilà il ya un
véritable besoin est ils message
on souhaite le faire passer pour une
course comme celle là pour un amputé
c'est le message qu'on va faire passer
tout le long de la course
on imagine une grande fête samedi ça va
être un défi physique on l'a dit comment
vous vous êtes préparés pour l'événement
selon elle paraît tout moi je m'entraîne
tous les jours pour dé talent triathlon
avec mon coach on a mis en place un
double entraînement entre le triathlon
jusque là je viens de rentrer de
tasmanie où j'avais une manche de coupe
du monde et en même temps sa plus longue
distance donc c'est un peu antinomique
je travaille sur de la courte distance
primtemps triathlon et en même temps la
de la très longue distance donc il a
fallu un petit peu adapté n'a fait que
je gère une petite blessure au pied en
même temps mais à mais bon voilà de la
préparation de fond beaucoup de beaucoup
de treilles beaucoup de longues
distances de l'accumulation sur les
trois disciplines du triathlon et puis
et puis bah on va se le dire c'est la
motivation aussi parce que 80 km y en a
beaucoup qui se passe dans la tête
donc vous a pas terminé puisque après
les 80 km et une ascension de la tour
eiffel jusqu'au premier étage exactement
bon là la vraie ligne d'arrivée en bas
de la tour eiffel et après on finit par
monter la tour eiffel le premier étage à
pied et là on a la chine schlein avec
les photos qui se fait à cet endroit là
moi ma motivation c'est que les
bailleurs à les enfants qui vont être
gérés par les associations qui vont être
présents à l'arrivée aussi à mes enfants
seront aussi présents donc on voit le
but étant de rallier les 80 kilomètres
on à 13 heures pour le faire ce soit
pour samedi on ne souhaite du courage et
le fait traverser cette ligue mais
également peut-être après une
participation à ces jeux de tokyo en
2020 merci à brice marmonnier par la
triathlète participants à ce 12e et
cauterets les jeux précis vous êtes le
premier athlète en tuant amputé à courir
ce 80 kilomètres ça on ne l'avait pas
précisé dans cet entretien merci d'être
passé sur ce plateau
un livre hommage qui est sorti
aujourd'hui nicole beltrame publie chez
albin michel c'était mon fils en
collaboration avec le journaliste arnaud
touche
elle y retrace la vie de son fils arnaud
beltrame le 23 mars 2018 le lieutenant
colonel de la gendarmerie amour est dans
l'attentât terroriste du magasin super u
de trèbes dans l'aude le gendarme décédé
en héros qui avait pris la place d'un
otage
arnaud beltrame avait suivi des études
au lycée militaire de saint cyr l'école
affecté ensuite au peloton et de
véhicules blindés à satory entre 2002 et
2006 il était revenu à versailles en
2015 pour intégrer l école européenne
d'intelligence économique la ville a
d'ailleurs rebaptisé une rue au nom et
d'arnaud beltrame
mercredi jour également de sortie au
cinéma pour notre petit tour
hebdomadaire dans les salles
saint-quentinoise direction ce soir le
grenier à sel c'est au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
nous l'avons tous remarqué le printemps
arrive et le printemps arrive aussi dans
les salles de cinéma donc dimanche 17
lundi 18 et mardi 19 mars 2019
les séances sont à 4 euros au grenier à
sel nous vous proposons la favorite
nous proposons aussi minuscule grâce à
dieu et weiss qui sont les quatre films
à l'affiché pendant le printemps du
cinéma
[Musique]
nous avons aussi un petit événement qui
aura lieu ce soir donc mercredi 13 mars
à 20 heures
c'est un débat sur le décrochage
scolaire
nous diffusons le film les gros esprit
le débat aura lieu après autre
information importante
il va y avoir prochainement des travaux
dans le cadre de l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 et ils auront lieu autour
du grenier à sel
le cinéma sera donc difficilement
accessible en journée il y aura en plus
des nuisances donc
au jour d'aujourd'hui je connais pas
encore la date de démarrage des travaux
mais soyez prévenus que en journée il
n'y aura pas de séance publique
à part les séances commenceront donc
commenceront à 18 heures en semaine et
auront lieu toute la journée dans le
week end
[Musique]
et puis c'est à découvrir au théâtre
montansier à versailles jusqu'à samedi
pour sa nouvelle création hervé van der
meulen met en scène un shakespeare
rarement jouée en france peines d'amour
perdues amour quiproquos et catastrophe
avec un parti-pris féministe mélanie
poquet c'est un pari un peu fou que le
roi de navarre et trois de ses
compagnons se lancent un pari rendu
impossible avec l'arrivée de la
princesse de france et trois de ces
dames avec peines d'amour perdues
hervé van der meulen met en scène une
pièce peut monter en france
une oeuvre de william shakespeare qui
fait appel à la jeunesse dans la
distribution baiia des anciens comme
matisse maréchal ouvra il ya des anciens
apprentis qui sont partis depuis deux
trois quatre ans notamment laurent pratx
qui joue le rôle principal qui avait
déjà joué pour nous beaucoup de bruit
pour rien qu'ils sont des anciens de
l'information dans quelques années
qu'ils sont donc réengager là comme tous
les intermittents et puis il ya une
dizaine d'apprentis
de l'escadre de l'école supérieure
d'asnières une pièce de 2h15 au rythme
enlevé hervé van der molen a fait le
choix de conserver la matière d'origine
une oeuvre résolument féministe écrite
vers la fin du xvième siècle me semblait
que c'était important de montrer que
shakespeare viennent avant tout le monde
avait déjà pensée féministe très forte
ce qui est d'autant plus étonnant
puisque les femmes n'avaient pas le
droit de jouer là l'époque les rôles
étaient tenus par des jeunes garçons or
tout ce qui est dit sur la femme dans le
spectacle dans la pièce est magnifique
normalement un plateau épuré pour
laisser place aux textes des incursions
contemporaine peines d'amour perdues
mêle tous les arts pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir cette pièce du dramaturge
britannique
oui et ça
[Musique]
c'est la fin du set 8 journal replay sur
notre site internet et votre application
mobile dans un instant le 7-8 débat
faut-il laisser les pharmaciens
prescrire certains médicaments sur
ordonnance et la question posée par
aurélie ronde à ses invités et belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]